>>Pat Ryan: Schools that close the
achievement gap do things differently,
and there are three conventional
wisdoms they do not subscribe to.
They realize they're actually wrong.
There are three counter-intuitive
truths that they understand,
internalize and drive their success.
>> So the first conventional wisdom
is that the thing that matters most is
to have a highly-skilled teacher.
Now, that's true, you want
a highly-skilled teacher.
There's no question about it.
But, in practice, great
schools are built by teams.
That team that's highly
aligned, that's focused,
that has a passionate commitment
to working together to achieve it,
all the great schools have that.
If we don't have alignment on
how we want to run the school,
what are the philosophies
and beliefs and practices
that we have, then it won't work.
It's more than just great
teaching that matters.
It's this highly-aligned
team, committed, passionate,
behind the right plan,
executing it well.
>>The best schools spend more
time up front on core academics.
You may have envisioned to have the
greatest writing program in the world,
but if your kids don't have basic
literacy skills you can't move
on to the next level.
You have to build one level at a
time, starting with the foundation.
That allows you to focus.
In the end, you want to
be great across the board,
but that's not how greatness is created.
You need that hyper focus.
You need to understand the sequence of
how things work and how to build it.
If you do that, then it's achievable.
>> The third conventional wisdom
is we're very focused on inputs.
We want to see good teaching.
We want to see good implementation.
We want to see that schools
are using best practices.
It turns out that the focus on inputs
fails to put us in a position to learn.
The great schools ask the
question, is it working?
Is our plan, the way we're
teaching, what we're teaching,
how we're teaching, is it working?
They're sitting down
together going, "Did it work?"
If not, hey, what are we going
to do different next month.
Oh, and by the way, how
do we help the kids
to make sure nobody gets left behind.
That continuous improvement cycle is the
secret to elite performance in anything.
If you look to get better,
you can create great things
where kids can achieve
whatever they're capable of.